من جهه اخرى نقلت القناه الاسرائيليه
الثانيه ع ان او عن مصادرها ان مسؤولين في
تل ابيب ابدوا انزعاجا من قرار واشنطن سحب
حامله طائرات من الشرق الاوسط وطالبوا
بتوضيحات واضاف التلفزيون الاسرائيلي ان
تل ابيب حاولت ثانيه الولايات المتحده عن
القرار في خضم التوتر مع لبنان واحتمال
تصاعد على الحدود الشماليه وقالت القناه
ان السحب حامله الطائرات الامريكيه يصادف
ظروفا لا تناسب اسرائيل واشارت الى
مخاوفها من سريان الاعتقاد في لبنان وغزه
بان قوه اسرائيل
ضعفت معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد نريد ان نعرف منك المزيد
حول هذا الاستياء الاسرائيلي من سحب حامله
الطائرات وكذلك العاجل الذي اشرنا اليه
قبل قليل عن الجيش الاسرائيلي بان السط
طات سترحل مئات من عرب اسرائيل وسكان
القدس المدنين بالارهاب الى السلطه
الفلسطينيه هذا غير دقيق بهذه الصيغه
الجيش اولا لا علاقه له بهذا الامر
الموضوع هو كالتالي هناك اقتراحات قديمه
جديده مشروع قانون يدفع به نواب من اليمين
مثل عضو الكنيست عمي هليفي من اجل سن
قانون يتيح لوزير الداخليه الاسرائيليه
سحب المواطنه اي الجنسيه الاسرائيليه ممن
ادين بما وصفها بعمليات ارهابيه وترحيلهم
الى خارج اسرائيل سواء الى مناطق السلطه
الفلسطينيه او اخرى اما الجيش الاسرائيلي
فلا علاقه له بهذا الشان ولم يصدر عنه اي
شيء رسمي وما يدور عنه الحديث حتى الان ان
هناك مشروع قانون وليس قانون وليس قيد
التنفيذ حتى الساعه هذه الموقف وهذا
المشروع والاقتراحات تقدم بها اقطاب اليم
على مدار السنوات الماضيه كثيرا وعادوا
اليها اليوم بمعنى انه لا يجوز لمن يحمل
الجنسيه الاسرائيليه ودين بتهم يصفونها
بالارهاب في داخل اسرائيل ان يبقى موجودا
يعيش فيها ويحمل جنسيتها لان اسرائيل ليس
فيها قانون ينص على
سحب الجنسيه او جواز السفر وانما تحتاج
الى قانون من اجل ذلك ولا يبدو ان هذا
سيكون قريبا اما بالنسبه
لمساله الحراك الامريكي المرتقب ابرزه
سيكون للمبعوث الامريكي الرئاسي عاموس
هوشين الذي سيصل الى اسرائيل اليوم من اجل
مواصله مباحثاته حول تسويه 13 نقطه خلافيه
على الحدود البريه بين لبنان واسرائيل
ويتوقعون بانه قد حقق تقدما في بعضها وهو
ما من شان مهمته هذه ان تحو
دون تصعيد او انفجار للموقف خلال تواجده
على الاقل بعد اغتيال اسرائيل للشيخ صالح
العاروري اما على صعيد قطاع غزه فواضح بان
اسرائيل قد غيرت من عملياتها الحربيه في
شمالي القطاع تحديدا الذي تقول بانها قد
احكمت احتلالها لمعظم وان بقيت هناك بعض
البؤر التي تواجهها في مناطق حيي الدرج
والتفاح وان معارك الاساسيه وهو ما كان قد
ركز عليه رئيس هيئه الاركان العسكريه
هيرتس هاليفي وكذلك الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي بان المجهود الحربي الاسرائيلي
الاساسي هو في منطقه خانيونس هناك تعمل
سبع الويه اسرائيليه مقاتله وتواجه اربعه
كتائب من النخبه تابعه لكتائب القسام
الذراع العسكريه لحركه حماس الجيش يقول
بان قواته تواجه قتالا ضاريا لكن انها
تحقق تقدما فوق الارض وتحت الارض اما
بخصوص باقي المواقع ف اللافت بان الموضوع
في الضفه الغربيه هو ايضا تصاعد صباح هذا
اليوم بعد ان قتل جيش الاحتلال مواطنا
فلسطينيا في قريه طمون وذلك خلال مواجهات
مع المواطنين وخلال اقتحامات الابرز هو ما
يجري في مخيمي نور شمس وطول كرم في طول
كرم وتحديدا مخيم نور شمس ل اليوم الثاني
على التوالي قوات الاحتلال هناك فرضت عليه
حذرا للتجوال وحصار عسكريا مطبقا وتقوم
بعمليات تمشيط من بيت الى بيت واستولت على
بعض المنشات حولتها الى معسكرات تحقيق
تقوم بالتحقيق والاعتقال على نطاق واسع
لكن الاقتحامات لم تتوقف في هذين الموقعين
امتدت الى منطقه نابلس وعدد من قراها مثل
بيت فوريك وقصر وايضا الى الحي الشمالي في
مدينتي رام الله والبيره المعروف بال
مصايف وبل قريه بيت ريما شمالي رام الله
وكذلك في منطقه بيت لحم ومنطقه الخليل
هناك اعتقالات كما يجري منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب التي دخلت يومها ال0 وحسب نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني فان اعداد المعتقلين
تتزايد وقد تجاوزت ال
5600 حسب احصائيه جديده قام بتعديلها ولا
يبدو انها تشمل وجود عدد هائل من
المواطنين الفلسطينيين زيين في سجن او
معسكر اعتقال سري موجود في منطقه تعرف بدي
تيمان في اقاصي النقب جنوبي اسرائيل وهم
في حاله مزريه ويتعرضون للتنكيل والتعذيب
وهذه الاعتقالات متواصله على نطاق واسع
شكرا لك وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره
كنت معنا من رام
الله